Старовинні вулички німецьких міст.
Тут не побачиш висоток зі скла і бетону або новобудов.
Кафе, крамнички й аптеки заховані за історичними фасадами.
Як у Німеччині збереглося стільки старих будинків?
Такі старі будинки можна зустріти в історичній частині практично будь-якого німе цького міста або містечка.
Багато з цих будівель мають статус пам'яток архітектури й охороняються законом.
Німецькою він називається Denkmalschutzgesetz.
Від Denkmal - пам'ятник, Schutz - захист, і Gesetz - закон.
Старовинні вулички в Баварії мають особливий шарм.
У конституції Баварії є положення про захист пам'яток - для збереження культури будівництва минулих років.
Завдяки йому ми знаємо, як будувалися будинки, з яких матеріалів.
Це дозволяє зрозуміти, яким було життя в ті чи інші часи.
Це важливо зберігати як частину культурної спадщини, яка показує життя минулих поколінь.
Таких об'єктів нерухомості в Німеччині - близько мільйона.
Але якщо ви думаєте, що всі вони віддані під музеї, то помиляєтеся.
За цими фасадами в більшості випадків кипить звичайнісіньке життя.
Частина будинків передається з покоління в покоління. Але є чимало й таких, які можна придбати. Однак - за низки умов!
На цій вулиці в баварському містечку Вайльгайм за 50 км від Мюнхена стоять 18 будинків, які визнані пам'ятками й охороняються державою.
Сім'я Коваленків купила цей будинок три роки тому.
- Привіт, заходь!
- Двері прямо музейні. Показуй, що ховається за ними.
- Перший експонат - плитка. Стара, розбита, але їй понад 100 років, тому вона охороняється законом.
- Тобто ми стоїмо на музейному експонаті?
- Так.
- А по ній можна ступати простим смертним чи потрібно якось злетіти?
- Так, можна.
- Ну, тоді веди.
- Тут обережно голову: старий амбарний косяк.
Господарі будинку зобов'язані зберігати автентичні "експонати".
- Ми в задній частині будинку, в коморі. Це гараж. Головний експонат тут - ось ця балка, на якій викарбовано 1911 рік.
Це рік, коли будинок ще раз перебудовувався.
- Якого року цей будинок?
- Офіційно за документами 1650 рік приблизно.
Якщо в будинку плануються роботи, то потрібно подати запит на дозвіл їх виконати.
І ми перевіряємо, чи узгоджується це із захистом пам'яток. Якщо ні, то ми відхиляємо цей запит.
Якщо все ж ці роботи проводяться, то в хід ідуть різні засоби, щоб не допустити несанкціонованих робіт. Наприклад, зупинити будівництво.
Об'єктом захисту може бути будь-яка деталь у будинку.
Наприклад, ці засувки на вікнах.
Заміна цих дверних замків також обійдеться господарям дорого.
Можуть накласти штраф до 250 000 за порушення правил захисту пам'яток архітектури.
Якщо в будинку щось із визнаного об'єктом захисту перебуває в аварійному стані,
потрібно узгодити або реставрацію, або заміну пошкодженої частини будівлі чи інтер'єру.
Ці сходи постраждали від термітів. Але поки господарі будинку вирішили їх залишити "для краси".
У майбутньому вони звертатимуться із запитом про їхню заміну.
- Це те місце, звідки ми, власне, сьогодні почали нашу екскурсію.
- Так, ми в гаражі.
Буквально кілька ліхтарів, кілька подушок, і він став лофтом зі старого запорошеного гаража.
У будинку ще належить провести чимало ремонтних робіт. Більшість з них мають бути схвалені відомством із захисту пам'яток.
То чи не простіше було придбати новий будинок?
- Було б простіше. Можливо, навіть дешевше.
Але від нового будинку просто зовсім інші відчуття.
Тобто це вибір: або ти будуєш свою історію з нуля, або ти вписуєшся в історію, яка вже існує, і ти розвиваєш її далі.
Тобто це фундамент для того, щоб будувати щось своє.